dans moins de trois semaines ce sont les
départementales les règles du jeu ont
changé pour ce nouveau scrutin les
cantons été redécoupée ils sont moins
nombreux mais paradoxalement il y a plus
de conseillers départementaux assiégé
puisque les électeurs vont désigner un
binôme de candidats auparavant le
conseil général étaient renouvelés par
tiers cette fois les élections
concernent l'ensemble de l'assemblée
difficile de faire des projections et
des comparatifs car les cantons ont été
redessinés toutefois certaines
projections peuvent se faire c'est le
cas pour le canton de montigny dont les
dernières élections remonte à 2008
le canton se compose toujours de
guyancourt et de montigny en 2008 malgré
une triangulaire le socialiste françois
de ligne et l'avait emporté dès le
premier tour avec près de 52 % des voix
pour ces nouvelles élections comme en
2008 le maire de guyancourt sera opposé
au maire de montigny le bretonneux
michèle losier aujourd'hui président de
la casse qui le challenge est donc
important pour l'union de la droite qui
tentera de conquérir ce canton autres
cantons qui sera scruté celui de trappes
il est aujourd'hui composé des communes
d'elancourt et de la verrière en 2008
alors que le canton ne comptait que la
ville de trappes
la socialiste jeanny de mari l'avait
emporté à l'issue du second tour face à
l'ump gérard fourgous le frère du maire
d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous qui sera candidat
pour ces élections l'ancien canton de
chevreuse et celui de maurepas ont
fusionné en partie un canton avec donc
deux conseillers généraux sortants la
socialiste is mais la vanne qui avait
profité d'un désaccord à droite entre
gerald de favier henry pailleux pour
l'emporter de moins de cent voix le
second est ump yves vandewalle
il avait été élu dès le premier tour
face notamment au maire de magny les
hameaux bertrand ou lyon deux autres
cantons étaient renouvelés eux aussi en
2011 celui de plaisir emporté au second
tour par le socialiste jean michel
gourdon face à la mer des
clayes-sous-bois véronique côté millard
avec plus de 60% des voix et celui de
saint cyr l'école où là encore il avait
fallu deux tours pour départager les
candidats
le socialiste jean philippe mallet
l'avait emporté face au maire de
fontenay le fleury
le mp jean jacques lasserre avec plus de
50% des suffrages
le premier tour de ces élections
départementales est fixé au dimanche 22
mars